الكشف عن اعداد الاتحاد الاوروبي وثيقه
سريه تتضمن خطه لمساعده الفلسطينيين
سياسيا وقانونيا واقتصاديا على بسط
سيطراتهم على المناطق المصنفه جيم التي
تشكل 60% من الضفه الغربيه المحتله قبل
بغضب اسرائيلي وترحيب فلسطيني نحن نتحدثنا
مع كل دول العالم حول انه لا يمكن القبول
بان يبقى الاحتلال يحاول منافع الفلسطيني
وبالتالي يعني العديد من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المصنفه تحت هذا البنت تحاول
حكومه الاحتلال السيطره عليها وبناء
وتوسيع المستعمرات الاسطانيه الوثيقه
الواقعه في ست صفحات تتحدث عن قيام
الاتحاد الاوروبي
بترسيم خارطه للاراضي في مناطق الجيم
والعمل قانونيا على اثبات ملكيتها
الفلسطينيه
ومراقبه النشاط الاثريه الاسرائيلي لانه
احدى ادوات فرض السيطره الاسرائيليه
والعمل من خلال مشاريع ود قانوني على دمج
مناطق جيم مع مناطق الف تحت السياده
الفلسطينيه وبال خاضعه لسيطره المدنيه
الفلسطينيه
فيما اعلى نوع وزير الماليه والوزير في
وزاره الدفاع مودريتش انه سيطلق فور تسليه
المنصب حمله لهدم البناء الفلسطيني في
مناطق جيم ويعمل على ضم الضفه لاسرائيل
هذه هي العلامه الاولى لما ينتظرنا من
توتر ومواجهه بين الحكومه الاسرائيليه
العتيده مع الدعم الاوروبي والامريكي
للفلسطينيين في منطقه تاسيس في الضفه
الغربيه
اسرائيل ترفض تقليديا اي دور سياسي
لاوروبا في عمليه التسويه وتصر على انفراد
واشنطن في ادارتها رغم انها لم تعد قائمه
منذ سنوات لا تخفي الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اليمنيه المتطرفه وشيكه الولاده انها
ستعمل على ضم الضفه الغربيه المحتله
لاسرائيل وانهاء حل الدولتين على الارض
ويبدو ان العلاقه الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه
المتفجره الطبيعه ستظل تدور في فلك تعقيد
والتصعيد زياد حلب العربيه الضفه الغربيه
المحتله